[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
when we talk about wherever we want and
I'm sorry I interrupted you but we have
Syd Wilder back I thought this is your
natural hair it is you be cheeky with me
my where you from right
Liverpool Oh lovely is that what the
girlfriend ring is I gave you that joke
before we went on the air you know it
you did you actually did oh he's so dead
he said it today girl you are we've I
had a babysit these [ __ ] kids babysit
this [ __ ] kids ran all over the place
you look like you were a beauty cleaning
your Haiti yeah let me tell you like
you're just I don't know ass be enough
cigarette voice oh no I always she did I
like that I think that's sexy what made
you one is to wear wigs okay thank you
for asking Bart um everyone gave me so
much [ __ ] about the last week I had
which I actually do agree with you like
that [ __ ] was shiny I didn't learn that
if you put dry shampoo on a wig it makes
it look more real oh I thought that that
was a bit no [ __ ]
which speaking of apparently Nikki
addressed this and since I am here I
have to say something okay I know it
looked like a homewrecker but my home
was actually wrecked by a lot of actual
home wreckers and Nikki and I have both
did you say or no what you have you ever
thought that like well we bought the
sheeted I'm sniffing oh yeah I mean yes
and so that pisses me off and I don't
like it when you guys leave those
comments so please don't leave comments
like that because everybody calls it a
homewrecker yeah this is me off because
I love Nikki and I respect but why would
you try to break up a relationship [ __ ]
I would never do that
I wouldn't and you still need to tell me
came out of left field cuz like she
texted me like hey people are commenting
that I'm trying to ruin your
relationship oh I don't go [ __ ] like I
mean we're
get that from though the comment I like
it hurts my feelings because I was
always self-conscious about that cuz
like I realized you know I look like you
know that person but I'm not and so it
makes me actually really uncomfortable
when I'm with couples because I'm like
[ __ ] I wish I know that feeling when
you're like man cuz my man cheated me so
you're Hershey it's really bothering me
I know I'm like their fly's troubling
you so whatever I just don't address
that so you think you're a homewrecker
please lay unsaid
just be nice to people you don't know
what other people have gone through to
ask you when you see a happy couple or
happy family together are you like I
can't wait to get between that's just a
question no it makes me really happy for
those people but I'm also like I don't
want to be I don't to trigger anybody
you know what I mean like I never want
anyone's your trigger being called the
homewrecker
no I just it hurt my feelings for Nikki
and I wanted to say something cuz I'm
here and I have this opportunity can I
ask are married men hotter no that's
disgusting you know actually the guy hit
on me and I told him I was married and
he kept it hey hey hey talk to me
only sorry yeah I know right girl I will
I promise all right hair girl it's the
hair I can tell myself I mean it looks
just like mine well that's why I said
after those funding that I said that
yeah I thought your wig was a bit
because my hair is a bit real here I was
writing tips wig it would look like we
switched here oh my god I mean this is
everything no this is like the
all-american mom you know
yeah just pig bar the blue I can't so
we're doing this we're doing this out of
solidarity for Syd thank you yeah we're
owning it and we are wigs it's so much
fun you expect me these types of wigs
don't like the actual like well few
weeks because your girlfriend has the
wig company so it's like she probably
what's your name Tessa Tessa I want your
wigs I'm sorry I have not I need to call
it back up on the DM but you're awesome
and I love your tutorials they're really
cool um shouts Tessa married gosh you're
that Apple anyway so um I thought that
you might you know but this is very 80s
yeah you're just went into her progress
how did you even know that we were gonna
have six by six weights
I know they're so expensive holder yes
oh yeah
she asked like [ __ ] can I bring all my
wigs and I'm like aw don't worry we
wrapped it in the proper I have a
beautiful pink wig with pigtails that
you will love it'll look great on you oh
really bring out the rosy and your
cheeks yeah thank you mr. Maron man I'm
giving everybody go clueless like the
movie not like your clueless okay this
petition drive way I can't see him
good good answer don't see any of like
middle school no was it it was like
fifth grade and I was so unfortunate
looking then I had like I don't even
know what I see pictures I know you have
he said this [ __ ] named Alicia Oh what
Alicia
we hate she's not real she the hawk and
real [ __ ] and she had like she was like
the hot girl or whatever and she had
like the hot boyfriend and like she
almost killed me with a look just a look
she have to [ __ ] say anything and
then when she did I start crying but she
was like why you looking at me was like
I'm ugly this is a topic of conversation
so yeah this feels yeah okay so anyways
you guys I love that you guys have a
patreon I have a patreon too and I've
been getting lots of guests on you plug
it yeah I'm gonna plug it because we're
here um go check out patreon Girl
Interrupted I have awesome new content
on there and I slave over it because I
don't have all of the help that you guys
have so I don't get a lot of sleep and
so if you like check it out would really
be awesome please get out so you do
everything you headed you upload your
them one thing I don't do is just the
audio I did a video which is why I was
asking him cause it takes so long to
like put it oh there's another Asian guy
he was another man who's also married oh
I was married to okay happened for that
long oh my gosh
my gosh this is so this is gonna be
called the most Awkward version of Syd
no it's gonna be called homewrecker oh
gosh that's really funny said Wilder is
a homewrecker question I am NOT a
question mark where it's a question
Sophia mean it's always the [ __ ] with
the cat ears that you should not trust
am i right yeah
is that an attack yeah first of all I
have these shoes on and every time I put
these shoes on do you remember these
shoes yeah what happened no remember
what did you like did you like I mean
yes I remember everything a wild story
we're at don't Dan is dead and and you
didn't have any shoes we were downtown
yeah yeah yeah yeah um and you were like
the first person I wearing cuz I had him
in my backpack and I was like you're a
girl here cuz it was lights it don't
look good for you you guys had a moment
and for Nikki it was nothing that's like
pretty much the basis of every important
relationship after someone tries to
break up my marriage I forget all the
more it is amazing don't so bad never
ever thought that about you ever thank
you cuz I love you and I'm just not I
hate those [ __ ] cuz I'm around all of
them you don't know that they're like
that and it's always the [ __ ] on the
inside that you have to be careful for
if you all now comment that below cuz
it's true
like look at Jordan woods who's that oh
my god you're such guys we're their
fiery girlfriend oh my god
exbest friend Kim Kylie Jenner's next
message is a girl kissed
Kylie's sister who's Chloe's they
probably [ __ ] probably oh wait can we
curse in here because it's youtuber
they'd be its patreon yeah
oh it's page this is patreon it's not oh
it's not I just don't even know it so
who's cut which one's Kylie Jenner the
one that makes the most money that one
the young billionaire okay yeah her
boyfriend kiss no no her best friend
named Jordan Woods
she kissed sister's boyfriend her
husband they have a baby daddy
baby daddy baby daddy I don't you
already know white guy know the bucket
dude did you guys hear that Miley Cyrus
is like let out I thought she did that
and then she was done yeah
yeah who is it one day she's gay and
then another day she'll be back with a
guy yeah yeah I don't she was like
gender-fluid first wasn't she
gender-fluid or something
how many times you defensive bingo today
I don't know you look like the dad from
[ __ ] oh my god I look like I should
have a claymore sword in my hand
you sure oh there's no swords around it
goes in there should be its office oh
okay yes I think that's chic anyone you
know they're always so [ __ ] accident
oh wow everyone needs that you can't
name yeah cuz those is one scene he went
back in time into the 70s when he was a
younger man and he had hair like that he
actually looks like he looks like he got
rejected from Game of Thrones
like like he tried out all the tape yeah
and like they didn't pick up speak some
Dothraki okay and you guys are like the
couple that's from a different decade so
your 80s and you seem more seven days to
me am i yeah so who met who first in
your big scenario do you looks like a
Jazzercise lady to kinda lady you look
like a Ronald McDonald head never mind
no what nope not gonna do sit down
syndrom no no no no I wasn't gonna be
bad you're gonna say you're gonna make
fun of those people wanna make fun of
the little people probably the little
short people maybe you want to stick to
home what's so hard when I come on the
show like [ __ ] you guys say some like
funny [ __ ] but it's kind of offensive
but it's funny it's [ __ ] I'm like I
gotta be careful I'm just reiterating
with the offensive series you're saying
me too I'm just trying to translate for
you people with Down syndrome is that
what you said
how dare you and anyhow you might hate
you went after the people who are small
you said they probably you said that all
tears are high chairs to them go after
people with bad wigs wait did you get
I'll really do you look after yourself
let's do it she said it put the lighter
fluid down all right I actually love so
I hate both of you so it's fine yeah we
never have to talk to each other again
ever back of it Nikki will you answer
what I asked you this morning what did
you ask Earl you know exactly what I
asked I think you a voice note win did
you maybe the wrong Nikki nothing is
meaningful to her it was I can't wait to
see you something about mean comments
every time I go to sleep in my mind cuz
you're like you can you're gonna fall
down a hole
the mooing yes yeah what the hell how do
you do that so they do that actually ijk
a news article it's really classic it's
a classic oh they change to the man but
there's like this tongue posture thing
that was like she was here for that
because I like them I told you about it
told me about it oh yeah so there's like
this dumb posture thing and there's
supposedly there's a lot of science
behind it I've never tried it or I'm
never not saying this is real or I'm
condoning it but there is supposedly a
lot of science behind it or research or
pew and tested groups that they've done
it but you can change the shape of your
face by holding your tongue a certain
way against the top of your mouth yeah
yeah yeah the tongue position of when
you say the ending of sing-sing and then
like so that the backyard tongue goes up
to the roof when you do that mmm right
so then you bring up the rest of your
tongue and that's the tongue posture
you're supposed to have yeah I heard it
like if you put your tongue on the top
of your mouth and then you swallow
that's like the end of your swallow how
did I get in another newing video then
Sid wanted to know
I had a moment that I forgot about and
then I remembered okay obviously I care
more if the conversation goes be
open-minded absorb dancing I was doing
the whole time I thought that of my
swallows very nice right
apparently if you do that long enough
cuz that's your proper tongue posture
that like makes your jaw more pronounced
pronounced yeah so you don't have to get
filler sure ya know what it's true that
she don't know if people get filler for
oh they get it everywhere I can't I'm
afraid to get you can't do that like
what parts do you want to make a jawline
more prominent is that what it does they
have like the Kardashian job because you
know it's like more chiseled or like
Angelina Jolie hers is natural Oh from
what I know but they like just inject
right here serum or like shaped I've
never done it but every time I go into a
plastic surgeon usually they're like you
need a chin implant I'm like you know
what stop talking about my Jen like that
well you try to create business for
myself exactly did you salsa dance shoes
that FIFA dances oh okay
can we see like it cuz you totally met
on drugs at the party in the 70s or 80s
whenever it was I feel like you were
salsa dancing maybe you don't remember
me that's it with this wig okay oh yeah
British Charles on rollerskates serving
up burgers can't we get a demo of the
dance though I want to see this like the
dance of love over here can we not see
it yeah what are we doing we're talking
about whatever we want
okay now what's the difference between
the seventies hustle and then the 80s
headbang okay but if this video gets no
views whenever they're bringing it back
on ever again this channel said what are
you like oh hi what are you like hi hi
hi how are you what are you like on
marijuana hi you speaking of drugs you
think I was already on them no no I'm
not good I'm not good no I I think
everyone is out to get me and I'm going
to die I am I fear [ __ ] oh my gosh I'm
like stop oh my god and like no one said
anything to me I'm like usually yeah
don't do it and I don't like how my
thoughts are like five minutes behind my
brain where I'm like did I think that
just now did I think that five minutes
ago
thank you it is and then you eat
everything yeah well I don't would say
it's mom just food when you're high yeah
I don't have saliva I'm pretty much like
on WebMD about it just like on there
like like why can I swallow and then I'm
like I can't put my eyebrows down oh my
gosh everything is wrong right there up
right here like this yeah that's what it
feels like down but you think they're up
I don't know I don't know basically
you're all annoying matches I know that
sounds like a really fun video Nicki you
should do it weapon do surgeon and also
like I like the elements really affect
me like I was in my friends living room
and I got cold and I was like oh my god
it's kind of cold
oh my god I'm freezing well I'm freezing
to death I'm dying I was next to the air
conditioning oh my god I'm [ __ ] dying
I think you should do a YouTube video hi
like Nicki hi are you tired those drunk
neighbors have you high means were
popular trended I almost did it but I
was like I just don't want to be blame
you know I don't do well any person
that's like been through a lot of trauma
usually doesn't do good with weed you
know yeah Oh
Halle girl there's like a Cali girl
through in through
I grew up with like weed being the devil
like it's like in your food group here
in California yeah okay in Georgia it's
like you're gonna go to hell you're
gonna burn in hell for burning that I
can't believe you go to hell for weed
mmm-hmm drug of choice then I love life
and dancing and on what phone call no I
can't do coke cuz I take adderall
everyday which is basically like the
same thing that's what it is yeah so
okay so adderall is basically cocaine
it's like diet coke element missing but
I've been on a riddle mister what
elements in like chemical missing from
it cocaine yeah do you know where
Ritalin came from no so there was this I
believe he was a scientist and he was in
Europe and his wife's name was Rita and
he wanted to get Rita lean so what he
did was he created the section he was a
chemist he created this concoction that
would get her to be more motivated to
play tennis and get her lean and so
that's where the the name Ritalin this
is a true story as where your drug
dealer yeah no no no no it's um have you
taken your pills its documentary on
Netflix you can check it out they talked
about it yeah it might not be like
verbatim the name of it but that's like
why do you take adderall every day I've
been on it since I was five years old it
was ritalin before it was adderal so
it's just been a part of my brain
chemistry and when my parents divorced I
actually went to a psychologist and they
did a lot of testing on me and that was
just I mean everyone in the 90s
basically put their kids on ritalin
because it was promoted so heavily so
Ritalin and Adderall are the same thing
just once a generic name or no well so
once adderall came out on the market it
was like it's rude one's competitor oh
oh then I don't know exactly what
happened because I didn't study that
part of it but you know once a dural was
on the market it just like took off but
when you say that you're you do
everything by yourself that's really not
true if you're doing a neural duty
that's a lot of help you know what I
gained weight on adderall really yeah
like it's like I still sleep I sold it's
not it's not something that I take that
I can just get like a high from like
literally I take it every day you don't
get [ __ ] done like a maniac no cuz I've
been on it right true I'm not some of
that
Oh No mm-hmm you're not taking enough -
you're not doing anything done I'm not
do we really want to double to double up
this is my second coffee for the day I'm
not gonna lie like that's like that's it
but that's what I expect from said that
is your brand that is Syd Wilder I wild
you are going for it every time which I
admire about you I try but I go for it
in a lot of different levels other than
home-wrecking I like feelings you know I
care about others other ways yeah that's
nice what's only because you told us
that you care about in so we have to
destroy you totally forgot about that as
I never even thought about it okay what
was the accusation
I guess people you know how like people
always comment like Oh Nicky and Joe and
their same side they're they're [ __ ]
or like Oh Stephen Jess we're talking to
each other
[ __ ] so he said that about Syd and
you I guess in some comments and course
Syd because she's been cheated on and
she sucks she's such a [ __ ]
sweetheart
she was like I never wanted anyone to
think that and so she texted me like hey
I'm so sorry like it came off as
flirting I guess but I didn't mean it
him but I was like girl you're fine no
one no one thinks that I'm like the
person thinks that text messages since
that mean I know who are you know oh
you're so sweet
no but it's leave her alone leave them
alone we could pick on her okay she's
our friend
you guys can cut this but said sent me a
weird text message to the other day
phone number you should cut that though
we shouldn't I want to show it to my
wife just so I'll show you what she
texted me to texted everyone emojis so
we could have all we could have been in
her in a husband group chat that she's
throwing you know it's all dudes in
there
yeah I think so I was wondering why I
have your number I have your number and
a half year I have all the chicks
numbers here okay fYI you're clearing it
up this huge said
see it's very well if you guys want to
hear about mental health because
obviously this is affecting mine this is
like a shameless plug I don't [ __ ]
care I just released the best episode
ever and dr. V is gonna come out giving
Thanksgiving advice if you have a
dysfunctional family please listen to
this because she gives great tips on
girl and stir up did in my podcast it's
free please go check it out and Maurice
Bernard talks about his battles with
bipolar and being an actor and how he
manages don't give it all away just go
make a listen to it so good and just to
compete with her real quick you can
check out this really cool Doritos
commercial where the chick is she bites
a Dorito it's from the 90s and then it
makes their account sounds only she's
wearing that way you could check that
video out to maybe instead I love that
sound
[Music]
[Music]